scp 682 versus a ton of liquid nitrogen  after trying and failing to kill scp-682  via anomalous means dr carlson wished to  return to basics and try some  non-anomalous murder methods for  bringing an end to this nasty lizard the  682 tissue sample was successful it was  frozen and shattered when struck with a  hammer exactly as intended however when  682 proper was doused with liquid  nitrogen its body remained frozen and  dormant for about 10 minutes then it  began increasing its body temperature  until it was thawed but it didn't stop  there it kept increasing its body  temperature until it was so hot that the  walls of the containment chamber began  to melt dr carlson noted  interesting it retained the adaptation  even after it was no longer necessary  maybe we should be more careful